back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
[Applause]
you said that's the only thing can't
asked Brendan oh why are you drinking
out of that thing which is a small
blender and burning hose is the only
thing they could carry like a lot iced
coffee yeah oh there's so many other
things to copy of to Anne's dude the ice
just take there's so much room so what
so it's called a bullet this is a bullet
blender cup bro don't try to act like
it's normal now while you're sipping out
of it like a trough over there like yeah
I have to stop talking while you drink
out of it cuz I can't see you drink out
of something oh you may event you have
soup at home in the bathtub [ __ ]
drink out of something oh man what's up
bro I was in Phoenix looking for your
mom oh really yeah
oh well she came because she lives near
there she doesn't come in a long time
dude she's in her late 70s oh yeah they
are late but uh yeah Brendan's senior
you should do a fun walk before in the
mall where they shut them all down and
old people walk through and give him
meatloaf and like I couldn't mashed
potatoes no as a lot of salt in it man
yeah you'll be careful with their health
you gotta give them different something
that they all worried about their
numbers where were you at numbers was in
West Palm it was crazy
for a minute with riffraff remember
riffraff oh oh he's alive
Jody high-roller yeah dude damn he's a
fan well there's nobody like him he's
that neon sasquatch you know dude
literally hanging out with him was like
hanging out with like a piece of science
or something like something that fell
off the periodic table and just landed
in the humanities it really
does it feel like you're hanging out
with Spencer's embody duty first of all
he rolls up I'm knocking on the door he
rolls up on a four-wheeler right and
he's like get on that bike in here and I
got on like a petal by on the back I got
away I was like tight at it hell yeah
crazy oh yeah pictures I didn't post any
people do not post pictures you can't
but you try to post him and they don't
post oh he's like a vampire yeah it's
crazy man he's next level I did a
podcast episode with him though oh so
you're gonna wait til that drops yeah do
I feel like you guys were separated at
birth yes there's similarities there's
similarities a little bit in the way
though Milo's no you look exactly the
same right but he looks like he was
colored with a neon marker yeah it looks
like he got shot by like a Silver Bullet
like they tried to kill him when he was
young it looked like his mom [ __ ] a
Nerf ball we're leaving that in but I
didn't say it that many the dude is
hilarious man I love games to when dude
he used to make me laugh when he's
trying to get big huh steroids I think
he's off of it now oh he had a [ __ ]
uh he had like a handful of [ __ ] stem
cells he was eating them like this when
I was over there
just [ __ ] cranberry stem cells maybe
the tangerine tiger tail damn Tony
brought with that million dollar mullet
son you and him if you and him create a
podcast it would be the best thing in
the world
oh dude like he should replace me for
sure no man if you die yeah okay I mean
you're gonna die yeah maybe especially
now the Jody high rollers
well torn [ __ ] I'm here a [ __ ] Brody
low roller brah you look like [ __ ]
Brody Jenner just [ __ ] came in
9,000th and a Lance Armstrong bike off
fro buckets
dude you're he look like Andre Agassi
brother the [ __ ] words I have ever
seen it looks like it's about love love
dude nobody's scored in this one though
you should be wearing a hat with you're
here you're here looks like a hate
crimes in Chicago get beat up in the
back well I think we're all ready to
start good Jodi High Roller C so Mike in
music dude II just play he has all the
sweet love ballad that he's gonna
inspire because he got clown raise on
that show yeah MTV tattoo on his neck
oh yeah did he I don't remember that
shut no I loved it
I forget Charm School I think was Charm
School and no one took him serious then
he was super skinny like he's on meth
and then he got off the show and then
he's like the most successful one Wow
yeah man it's a cool story I didn't know
that night but yes I love that show I
don't even know that do you that's so
funny I don't even know that I just knew
- he's the only white guy really wow
what a first of all brave guy okay super
brave also not that brave dude you go on
a school nine of the guys at school or
black how do you not win the contest
that's what I'm like yeah oh well then
there you go that was great yeah it was
good because he got started on New York
New York right wasn't he contestant on
there why is he really I thought so and
then you got put on that other show you
got boat offer she was crazy remember
she tried to repossess her mom's fake
tits remember that later yeah I was
gonna crazy yes mom
yeah who looked like the female in
gremlins too when she got all crazy but
they lived a mom the mom was like
gremlins - mom oh yeah remember there
was a fire and they both put on like a
the wrong wigging came out real fast or
something yeah one like David
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's get this done all right we got
Derek posting in the shotgun seat today
man wearing that Baltimore Orioles hat
huh yes sir man got it for my girl oh
don't go to Baltimore she from there oh
we're gonna start with some way it bid
or did the first one the first one is
from subscribe for the what is Wed Wed
bed or dead it's kind of like [ __ ] marry
or kill yeah okay subscribers in yeah
just you guys are gonna do it your own
spin on it
alright you know okay so it's like [ __ ]
marry kill but Wed better dead so
where'd Mary bad sex
dead deceased if you could to see
something glad you [ __ ] that down cause
Akon there's bedbugs all right you're
like spiders weds
and I'm like nope we're reading
Charlotte's Web Alicia from Long Beach
poor web better dead so wet better dead
Gabrielle Union Janet Jackson or
Christina Milian let me know Buzzz Buzzz
gang gang man is pretty a yes yes look
at that smiles got a beautiful smile
dang Christina Milian's suddenly Derek
just took his Orioles hat off all of a
sudden their first game yeah on claim
territory
about the lesson I would say I'm gonna
start off with this I actually
interviewed Christina Milian one time
Wow she's don't wanna go uh this is
probably two and I had three years ago
you should hook up with who little Wayne
she was like little Wayne saw it item
you know she was she was that Kentucky
Fried sticking for little Wayne he was
just that was that drive-thru you know
she's them french toast oh dude yeah she
seemed like a straight Wildcat dude real
freak a leak you know she's somebody
that you know Flavor Flav would [ __ ] you
know even free clock I'm talking pre
clock before time began BC and uh and so
I think Christina Milian would have to
be the sex partner what's other options
there we go got Janet Jackson and
Gabrielle Union oh definitely killing
Jeff Jackson well she's just like her
brother
yeah after the same doctor get their
noses done so I can't [ __ ] Michael
Jackson so I'm gonna have to kill you
yeah man uh yeah I think also she's if
she keeps looking like Michael she's
gonna go on trial from less than him
kids I know that you know they're
confused now yeah at some point look if
the nose fits wear it
you know what I'm saying if though if
the nose fits we can acquit that's what
they're saying announced with Ronald
Glover is saying so I think that that's
definitely deceased Janet or IP though
dude alright P two steps forward two
steps back
I think one step back we come together
cuz opposites attract remember dude you
look like the cat from that video
definitely married but you look like a
tennis line judge at EDC dude look
[ __ ] horrible bro you look like
somebody who gets hired to [ __ ] cut
Tiesto's hair dude
[Laughter]
Jonah's transitioning coach definitely
married Gabriel Union she is
yeah that's Dwyane Wade's why can he
seem like a good man dude from every
vibe you get out of that guy's him like
he's a real stand-up gentleman he's a
gay son
he does he really yeah Levin year I went
to a gay parade and [ __ ] oh wow really
that's a little younger first of all to
be sending your kid to a parade I don't
care what type of parade it is well
Gabriel went with them okay yeah
he's accompanied by an adult oh that's
good yeah cuz otherwise dude you know
all men can be real the silliest but you
get gay men out there with an
eleven-year-old that's that body style
running away that's on you yeah that's
on you as a parent if yeah molesting if
he has 11 year old Dwayne Wade body Oh
what are we talking about it looks like
a 30 year old yeah dude jumping through
the roof LuPone James bro you feel me
huh yeah Wow but anyway uh yeah I think
Dwyane Wade seems like a real stand-up
dude I bet his wife is Stannis I'd have
to marry the Dwyane Wade's wife I'm with
you but you can switch it out just so we
don't agree on everything I'll I'll
marry a million million really yeah
since she came up all my millions here
she's a real night Millie air yeah I can
see y'all fighting without an interstate
yeah me too I like brown style yeah I
can see that dude no fighting though no
[ __ ] this [ __ ] talk just her biting yeah
okay I like that man what else we got up
next we got this is from Drew Hut from
envy old Nova Scotia Canada oh wow so
this could be a cry for help
yo Theo and Brendan drew from Enfield
Nova Scotia Canada hey got a wet bed or
dead for you taking it to old school
with the Golden Girls oh nice Bea Arthur
Betty White a room McClenahan be good
which one are you gonna wet better dead
gang gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz he was like
nice first of all pretty cool dude that
our show plays back in time and at this
guy I'm just joking
I've heard it's beautiful over there in
Nova Scotia man it's cold it's [ __ ] yeah
you
yeah everybody looks like they're just
trying to stay warm you don't take a
white Walker in flannel yeah like a warm
Walker
yeah stay together but no that's that's
cool you listen to the show man this is
our first got from Nova Scotia I think
ever to submit a submit yes positive
mean he might have the only electric
line out of the I must have the only
cell phone that's a higher community
he's probably hiding right now that's a
great game up there hide and go cell
bars searching for service I can go
communicate I've seen this showing a hot
second officer in question and still no
joke you put an episode of this or
Frasier on and you are still good to go
instead of search and you got a lady
comes over middle of the night you
putting on [ __ ] these other shitty
shows [ __ ] Larry in the swamp or
[ __ ] who killed Randall or any of
this [ __ ] do all of that golden girls in
chill bro holding girls in Tuesday cuz
golden girls women let's it lets women
know or young men that love the golden
girls that you're into that sort of
thing you respect women mmm or you can
watch milf for everyone to well be
Arthur was a straight G bra is that the
one in the far left
oh she was two seasons away from [ __ ]
marrying a woman yeah she was kind of
the gangster of them right she was kind
of the leader yeah she was the hard head
kind of issues the brains of the
operation of that old operation not that
they were doing too much like if you
remember the shows all they did stay at
home all day
yeah and they just went on for season
after see they did nothing well Stan
would stop by sometimes and try to fix
[ __ ] and see if Dorothy would take him
back yeah that's right that guy [ __ ]
yeah he was dude Betty White's the other
two are dead I think Betty White's the
only ones still alive and she might be a
mommy no she is I know a dog lover or
she just can't doesn't know the
difference being dogs and people anybody
think she's mummified I'm pretty sure
she's a mommy now but talks I'm like
Teddy rough skin but mommy stop like you
pull a cord on the back of her she's
like I can st. all of you I'm happy to
be here that's from the forties they're
propping up I'll do it over under right
now dude since you lost on that Dustin
Poirier fight dude what you want to bet
I'll do an over/under on the Betty White
life I'll go lice
with you right now and be doves uh uh
what do you mean how long will she live
dude one of us gets her over one of us
run 200 huh
over under 200 I'll go 100 I'll go
hundred $40 but how long do you think
she's gonna live though I would like
how's she now though I'm not sure Derek
100 I want two to one odds for the next
18 months 97 back 9 bro
it gets bumpy on that back nine yeah
hold on you bumpy see for willing in
life right now in a [ __ ] Volkswagen
model just [ __ ] oh a strong Jam we'll
take her out yeah bro a [ __ ] enough
strawberry preserve [ __ ] little tangy
rhubarb pie Ted dead or just reading
that's a game that she's playing a lot
I'm joking first of all I love Betty
White
one of the funniest women out there
funniest people but also one of the
funniest women she had a style of her
own man that's you know sometimes you
get a lot of a lot of a lot of comedians
just try and rip off there's somebody
else's style the reason why any of them
I feel like have a success sometimes is
because they find their own style and
she had a style all her own and she
still will for for the next 18 months
play game dead or just having pie pie
naps hire dead people the eating platter
they dead so the over/under 18 months so
I get 18 months over bro really oh yeah
she may be you know at least hundred
five and I bet you might and so that's
beautiful so we're going 140 dollars I
want two to one deal you get three to
one deal
is that the way odds work or not yeah
he's from Baltimore did your lady will
no that's her Baltimore people know
what's up they know number two they sell
them gram gram crackers maybe Oh Grammy
Grahams that girl's a nice Jesus Christ
but can I just kill all of them are they
all dead wow I would never do that
look I have too much respect for these
women man so you know I'm also gonna
marry Betty cuz still alive we can share
the money find easy way out and then I
guess I'll [ __ ] the far one on the left
the brain in the operations and they
kill the middle one although all of them
are staring like in the Grim Reaper and
the [ __ ] eye everyday know a lot of
beautiful women him and Bea Arthur left
early and also what about Sofia what was
her name do you have her name on there
somewhere there is that the fourth one
yeah there's for the most gold yeah but
they I don't know the fourth there was a
fourth use the bronze girl yeah damn I
didn't know then silver sidekick about
the silver surfer dude no you're talking
about Three's Company no no no no
there's four do my little Three's
Company Hugh stuff we've been waiting
for you
[Music]
don't need you Three's Company two
hotties on there bro oh just one dude
two hot chicks Suzanne Somers and he
could never all the summer he never mind
any of them as he was too busy going to
open the door all the time ever all you
would do is rush together you know see
him anyway close it and if I can fix
something and then go back and open it
and we all babies run into the kitchen
and the dark-haired lady would be in
there empty in the dishwasher and she
would solve the problems and he'd go
back out and room it was a great show
dude what's your name do we know her
name do you Tom Tales from the Crypt
from the Golden Girls she's in tells
from the Crypt same lady really yeah
same lady Jean Tales from the Crypt yeah
what's her name the Crypt Keeper
are you a patria Sofia patria no that's
their stage name - I had no idea there's
four of them also I'm young sorry not
Rio know her real name Sophia Petrillo
What's it saying Sophia
Estelle Getty right there look how look
how beautiful she was most likely born
in 1905 in Sicily she looks like [ __ ]
Gregg Popovich's a little side piece
dude dude she looks like Drew Carey if
he got super thin so fake drew careless
bro she looks [ __ ] I'm joking she's
beautiful lady looks like she's best
friends with the [ __ ] touch of death
bro I don't want to go too dark on it
well let's just his question guy dude
the guy wow you're heartless look man I
know that our senior citizens need love
as the child of a senior citizen I grew
up watching these woman and thinking
they were fine as [ __ ] dude my dad told
me they were I can see that so I Blanche
was always a hot one but she never
really did it for me always kind of like
you know uh I liked that Stern woman so
I go with that tall piece of water whoo
[ __ ] I lost you all know that oh that
that's all [ __ ] nice sickled right
there graham cracker and a titty second
graham cracker crunch boy what's her
name
Beverly Dorothy Dorothy yeah I go at
Dorothy baby you know I'm saying there's
no place like home
you feel me Oh bear went over to the
mountain to see what he could see boy
and so I would make love to Dorothy and
then I would marry Betty white because
be entertaining gonna have a great time
and then I'm gonna cut kill the old one
that's missing from the picture when I
kill do you mean you would just shut a
door could you just die from the air no
I drop a book about six feet from her
back behind her
toss her my backpack Wow dude I'm gonna
start calling you glance I'm strong dude
cuz I look over to you and I see a real
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's coated a drink out of your big
[ __ ] wine bucket there dude I've
tosser this do it yeah I'm Civic yeah
maker clean out your coffee cup wants so
[ __ ] dislocate her hip getting down
in there on the ladder you get your life
together man plant at home at your house
that's [ __ ] just laying out as no pod
today cause you chose if I can drink out
of it bro
dirty reforest er all right then and
then so no I would decease the old one
and then oh because the other three are
still you know you got it you got to
keep the living living they still got
some time to kill and so I would I would
have them three be alive for sex and
I'll kill them all relationship Harry
Wow okay there you go what else we got
nowt everyone's favorite time it's a
commercial from King in the state oh man
I'm gonna talk about this you mind
burnin no please man just make sure it's
fresh oh dude it's fresh look I've been
taking care of myself physically and
even though that's hard to believe even
if you ever have seen me your skin looks
good though oh thanks man well that's
because I'm hello fresh I've been eating
hello fresh I can only have the meats
and vegetables right now because of the
diet that I'm on but I can also have the
cheese and the eggs I just can't bread
up but hello fresh is a delivery service
that I absolutely love it makes
conquering the kitchen a reality with
delicious simple recipes you order the
recipes online they send them to you you
get the recipes you pay forever though
huh no they like six hours to make a
meal on dude takes 30 minutes
to make a meal Bam Bam Bam you're a chef
bro you're a ratatouille whatever you
want to be do it even animals could do
this man it's beautiful you get all the
ingredients you get your son in there
your little dime piece your side item
you got twin girls whatever give them
each a little Barbella or a bell pepper
let them chop them up what if I'm
vegetarian vegetarian brothers they got
vegetarians salutatorian magna [ __ ] laude
anybody that wants it you can get it I'm
not joking hella fresh you go to the
site they got beautiful meals chicken
this pesto that rosemary your mama bro
everything they have three plans to
choose from classic veggie and family
with the option of veggie sorry swaggy
bruh dude shoutout to my boy Tim veggie
out there outside of Pittsburgh enjoy
enjoy fun menu items with hellofresh is
dinner to lunch 20 minute meals gourmet
and one-pot wonders among more do let me
save you guys some money for $80 off
your first month of hellofresh go to
hellofresh dot-com slash cats that's K
80s 84 $80 off your first month of
hellofresh go to hello fresh com / K 80s
80 and enter K 80s 80 that's how to do
it get the deal get that hit or get
hellofresh
tighten up fill your gullet man it's
nice it's just like cooking old-school
but this is the newest way to do it and
still feel like a chef that's how I feel
about it
someone's got to pay for Brennan's
coffee habit up next we got King
understand yo first is Matty Mac from
Santa Monica Oh many more local dope
and it decorated soccer players to shut
up him and get to you guys for having
that song as the outro I had a bunch of
your fans reach out and say that my
music has helped them through some dark
times so thank you for giving gang baby
they're lying
help some people out I got a different
King interesting it today gonna go into
my other area of expertise so I want to
know King it or sting in this custom
Buzzard so here we go bro soon lutely
custom King Ghidorah sting it buzzer box
from scratch I 3d designed the whole
thing I printed it a 3d printer and I
used my electrical engineering degree to
oh he's a terrorist guess is this so
you're gonna see let's try to put a bomb
it's from Jersey in charge in the mood
[Music]
that [ __ ] it's fire and in the back
there special for you and we have a
volume knob because this thing will get
pretty loud I know you guys had issues
on one of the other podcast you said
something about the batteries and it's
probably easier for Thea to get
batteries you just grab him when he's
finishing up his shift at his dad's
hardware store but dang bro oh my god
dude is that our dad her dad just stop
let's you for Christmas we didn't think
he was gonna come but I bought some
gifts that's Maddy Mac New Jersey Maddie
Matt dude I can't wait to get rid of
that man I met him at from Santa Monica
it may see our ma TT ma si Matty Matty
Matty back in J you can find him on
Matty Mac NJ on Instagram and hopefully
I'll put that buzzer up there so people
can go get a peek at it it's pretty dope
man get that buzzer in studio yes it
degree now I know you there's part of
you where you probably didn't know what
was going on which degree is it's like a
if you go to school for an extended
period of time to give you an award of
here
the in award yeah oh no matter what now
do they young no matter what are you
away no matter what like your mom did
she's like I you know I just take it I
had this printed out for years now just
yeah just [ __ ] take it you got all
these but whatever you put in the effort
I guess by putting effort you woke up
today here yeah you get an F for effort
after forever baby shout to that dude we
got to get that in here that was dope
yeah man that's crazy
what do we even do I feel like we just
we should watch the tutorial like it was
good do songs
dope is it until the outro song did we
switch it I don't we use the box so we
should alternate them then be pretty
cool probably huh yeah we should
definitely put this back in because
that's the king in the reggae with it
that's cool docking and a sting King is
right down by the beach boy back bus bus
bus man [ __ ] boy
[Laughter]
get who wants a little bit of star
vodkas come into the Starbuck us dude
one time I was in uh somewhere tropical
you know sure kind of I think it could
have been Barbados or it could have been
Haiti here somewhere kind of chocolate
and tropical right Florida and and I
dude I
they had a Starbucks sign outside of a a
business right so I'm like oh it's a
Starbucks right I go inside dude the
ladies like welcome to the Starbuck a
lounge that's what she said it was like
four people just hanging out in there
she's like can I get just muthi a
smoothie you're just taking a Starbucks
high and put it off outside breaking
[ __ ] pineapple Sammy's story someone
know pineapple smoothie
bro they had a little finishing with no
fish in it and then had a blender and
some people playing Domino's all the
time say for a long time
a couple of joints best Starbucks ever
been to my entire [ __ ] life there's
no smog come get the carribean go go go
go buzz soccer balls flying through the
air way you drink like yes uh what was
that lady's question we haven't even got
to the question yet this is a Cody from
Utah Cody from Utah this is Cody coming
you out of Utah beautiful can't get her
sting it for you
dogs with human names like Roger or
Bobby
Topher's actually named out of are named
after
[Music]
Chris the LEAs character in that one
episode of workaholic she had so yeah my
dogs named after a fictional pedophile
I'm not sure if he's a pedophile
what's up to him if he wants to do you
don't don't limit him on me in my life
anyway giggity giggity buzz buzz giddy
thanks for doing what you do were top
dog um
I mean if you got a basic dog um a human
name but not mad
no not like Dave like that sucks for the
dog but also I can see like if you have
one of those spud Mackenzie dogs I
forget what they're called
you know what those spud Mackenzie dogs
they look like Scott Ian look if you're
if you got a spud Mackenzie dog it looks
like Scottie Pippen calm Scotty that's
cool yeah that's pretty cool you have a
specific type of animal you call it
wah-wah with a mullet called deal oh
yeah dude all like that idea that's a
spud Oh bull bull terrier that's right
bull terrier do you remember spot
Mackenzie like the party well he had on
the search he was drinking beer yeah
he's that one dude that day yeah that
dog was really exceptional he's an apple
never rin-ten-ten k-9 cop hmm he was a
dog and he helped people last he helped
find help Timmy find somebody was always
in a hole like about 80 feet from his
house yeah no they didn't believe
ya see was some bullsh every time it was
like some dude got stuck in a hole and
she just barked yeah and then I go she's
so smart
yeah and then he would bring a rope over
there remember mr. Edie oh yeah horse
horses a horse
yes right dude [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
tonight dude dude Nick all night Oh bro
I'd stay up dude black-and-white
television yeah yeah praying for color
bruh and then the Lord came through he
did was got Lord with the markers coming
from Utah oh yeah now if your dog now I
ran across this one time they had a lady
with a service animal named
after her brother had been hit by a
vehicle and died and I felt like it just
seemed like a lot of pressure on the dog
you know like see that you know and like
she died Greg yes probably pretty sad
still yeah yeah and it was first name
and middle name the dog had of her
brother that had passed away and it's
just but also it's confusing like four
had a dog park and people like Brandon
he named your [ __ ] poodle Brenda yeah
be doing dude give it a [ __ ] dog
named your dog for a reason or Chelsea
Handler yeah what are you doing yeah and
like yeah I feel you dude if the dog has
a dick nose name it Brendan yeah if the
dog has [ __ ] dope hair nice clavicles
name it Theodore but yeah you can't have
the name like Sherman
now Edie granddad granddad Wilson that
can't be your [ __ ] gold ring Gertrude
though Greyhound what do you think on
this Derrick I feel like we're coming to
a standstill I can't listen to burn and
talk for I need a break
don't name your dog a dog name and then
get a real friend in real life and
they'll have a real name okay don't
don't you seemed kind of desperate ed
you just want to hang out with some dude
clearly okay go get a real friend yeah
if you got all nine dogs
one of them's just named fine ass man
and I won't lie it just means that that
you might be a lonely woman yeah yeah
that's exactly what's going on or if
you're a woman and you got like six dog
you know but no single woman has dogs it
she was just cats and she she don't [ __ ]
with the dog oh I wonder why where there
was that one lady had that pet monkey
was just [ __ ] the monkey I remember I
ripped her face off in hand before you
ever saw that Geraldo uh-uh yeah and the
monkey they were giving the monkey like
wine and xanax and [ __ ] he was in a robe
she'd like suck him off and then one day
she came over with another dude and he
was like what the [ __ ] is this cool
story even though I'm on xanax and on
red wine I'm gonna rip your face and
hands off true story look it up dude
really yeah you gotta be careful tapes
it sounds like an Angus day that sounds
like an after party a joke
that's you know it still really haven't
broke yeah dude
and it was at a welterweight champ about
what weight class are we talk to same
genre and I don't know why do women
let's go to cash she's a female
currently we're not judging you if you
want to do whatever you want to do cat
and is kind of a real [ __ ] but it's
your life say this yeah it's your life
is what I mean it was transition in
Neyland do whatever you want of
transition into a [ __ ] hardware store
workers son what do you think women not
dogs straight women well people say that
dogs are more like children and cats are
more like roommates I think that's to
fill the void of not having somebody I'm
not a character you okay nope I try to
be I try to wake up sometimes in the
morning but how I can do it I could do
it today I could love a cat I could care
I could come home and look for it they
don't care no cats are serial killers
that's the thing they don't care if they
cared a little if a cat never I've been
in a neighborhood a stray cat comes up
hey put some effort in yeah you want
love put effort three cats hiding it's a
one-way road they eat and [ __ ] go
hide forever they don't give a [ __ ] no
dude we should not be on their planet
that's where I think we landed early
they might be aliens well thinking oh no
dude I was thinking it also get your
[ __ ] out of my face cats tails
hurries up and their asses are just
hanging out I mean that's kind of the
sexy part I think of them mmm
interesting bye but yeah I think that's
a good point cat that a lot of you if
you a dog is more like something you
really have to take care of a cat you
can and cats eat you when you die how
many times we're gonna read that news
article correct every day it's getting
old CNN woman had nine cats yeah CNN
will be like nine Republican cats eight
a woman after she died it's getting
really real all right let's keep it
moving but good question man yeah unless
your dog is like if it's getting real
scary you know if you need my father if
you date him Danny or Ralph I'll
entertain Ralph yeah Oh Ralph il is
burning
often refers to one of the Ninja Turtles
yeah I dig it up next this is from
Rachel mellow Rachel Miller what's up
guys this is Rachel from Denver Colorado
no do you own 7mu dream can you sing it
for you female strippers what do you
think about them would you date one yeah
just give me your thoughts about it uh
also [ __ ] love you dudes you guys are
awesome just finished watching your most
recent podcast um yeah love you guys
game game no call me I'm gonna close
your mouth are you anything did you have
a boner no I don't you wanna use your
dick sucked and buy some turquoise off
of her relax okay well if a completely
that is true boner Patrol
I'll take the boner or of 140 Opie's
look man all I'm saying is you got 18
months to [ __ ] kill I got 18 months
to kill Betty White mm-hmm get that
money I'll buy a couple voodoo dolls off
this bed yeah this is bad young lady
right here
Mallory what's her name her name was a
raging feet Rachel sorry uh female
strippers yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah what do
you like about it they're an awesome man
good people they're really good
education might have daddy issues but
they have good communication to listen
to your problems
they're basically therapists with
finance bodies and tits yeah you can go
then just get your problems out then get
your [ __ ] blue balls yeah Pam and
it's half the price of a therapist I dig
it man I celebrate I'll see some best
people I know are strippers really yeah
they got their [ __ ] together they work
hard
you came in houses and [ __ ] the biggest
king of all time and I'm a fan of her
and her turquoise and mood rings
dang okay
somebody yes he definitely seen like
Willie Nelson's daughter kind of she
kind of has that vibe a little bit or
angels yeah she definitely seems like
yes I'm Criss Angel pulled out of a
sexy-ass hat yeah here's what I would
like to say what was she talking about
female strippers Oh female strippers
yeah I mean as compared to male
strippers yeah what I don't like is they
only do it indoors it's only in these
secret spots I'd love to Bisbee going
for a run and you see a female stripper
over there just earning money with a
head out there by a palm tree
oh no I'm saying outdoor strippers yeah
why is tan [ __ ] yeah why strip and just
become an indoor event we have to be in
these dark seedy places where some other
corporation is making money off you
selling alcohol and charging the cover
to cover that charge it you don't get
any of the pennies for why don't you be
able especially in some of these states
like Colorado slavery it really is in a
lot of ways like why can't I go to
Venice Beach and see some do geena's lap
dance you know yeah you should be able
to skateboard and lap dance yeah you get
at somebody can have a kiosk in the mall
selling you [ __ ] ass hand lotion but
[ __ ] diandra right here can't [ __ ]
show a little bit of work down there
about a beach you know right by the
beach but I can get my back rubbed at
the [ __ ] mall but I can't get my dick
rubbed with her ass cheeks same thing
doing through my Dockers do it through
the darker that's yours and that's your
brain for you pros here's a little tip
wear sweats to the club really yeah we
busted we busted a baby prices oh are
you a guy who's just saying he's
ejaculate and inside of buildings at
night yeah and sweat well that's crazy
Reeboks oh dude you're a future middle
school PE teacher yeah easy junior high
if you really want to see some young tit
bring it on shotgun willies baby first
of all shotgun yeah uh yeah you seem
like a nice young lady and nice teeth
yeah beautiful young lady I think the
most tripperz is fine you know I've had
ladies a better danced in my family and
you know it's I mean it's they're very
similar to me to comedians because they
they get on stage they're kind of
putting it all out there but in a
different kind of way but in a way
they're really kind of
entertainment yeah they're entertaining
you're up late at night you're just
entertaining you know and you're using
whatever you have that are a way that
you enjoy entertaining people you're
using that to be interesting
cut the [ __ ] give me a real name don't
tell me your name Cinnabon hey that's
not helping me yeah my boner if anything
be like the guy who names his dog the
real names at least give yourself a real
name yeah let's go be a hot name Earl
I'm cool with that yeah
don't pick a strip mall name or an
airport strip mall name this is an issue
I think new issue with strippers or
strip payers as some people call them Oh
what's your name peach [ __ ] don't say
my kid peach yeah a lot yeah the names
also they're picking names out of like
airport like aunt Annie like that ain't
your name also here's another great
thing strip clubs the DJ heed Cindy come
on down I love that [ __ ] you do check
out Cinnabon yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah
but they all have those town cry or like
that's not your name that is a that is a
newsstand at an airport you know they're
picking names they just saw in the
airport now Kerry yeah oh my name's
chick-fil-a yeah my name is wheelchair
accessible bathroom like I don't believe
that you gotta make up a name that is
more fun and exciting you know what
about vertigo we stand this sure I like
that
back in Louisiana she'd get dizzy on the
stage and fall off and vertigo would
come on the stage and so all the guys
that kind of put their arms I was like
watching a bumper bowling that wouldn't
end
dude that's been that yes yeah yeah
that's pretty cool man
so I'd like to see more adventurous
stripping you know more rogue stripping
I unfold yourselves yeah it's easy to be
on the stage and don't stay on the pole
when you can see everything you know I'm
saying be that risky you know what about
that free solo wasn't that a thing
yeah where's free solo the stripper I'd
love to climb a rock naked yeah Clint
you know how many people watch these
holes climb the rock without a rope yeah
free polo and it's just that tallest
pole is 700 feet high
yeah going up yeah and it's greased up
yeah we just want you tried to survive
and the grease has change at different
levels do it it gets hotter as you go ha
yes hotter as you go up it's like it's
don't man somewhere athletic huh yeah so
we put their ass cheeks just on the bar
that cooks the bar yeah yes sometimes
you'll see the girl
the bar with our ass cheeks and hands
and arms straight out away from the bar
unbelievable bro of real talent that's
me real talent it's different time of a
stripper Draft yeah yeah like a seven
round draft just the hottest strippers
in America
you're been to Magic City in Atlanta no
I don't do all of that man I don't go to
strip clubs
well you haven't been at this strip
clubs really lose all your money
go to a show down there go to [ __ ]
Magic City
you ever seen any rap video ever that's
where they're at bro really and they
would get their hands on your
gender-neutral haircut what are they
doing what's wrong were they doing
celebrating life with their ass pop pop
pop pop pop making it twerk pop pop my
baby County go pop pop pop my bank oh my
it looks unsafe a lot of the movements
it looks like a clinic is there a magic
City chiropractor club right next door
there bro yeah they're snapping necks
snapping checks bro yep snapping necks
and cashing checks but look I've been to
some strippers over there throw up throw
up dude
I am on keto diet dude oh okay I'll lick
that [ __ ] facial moisturizer off a
because it looks like a [ __ ] has
sugar in it it looks like yes fatty
uh-huh yeah you trying to lose weight no
I don't know bro what are you trying to
lose weight for I don't know I somebody
told me about the diet and so I started
it all right I'm proud of you man keep
stick with it it's miserable did almost
cry damn own mouth for flavor last night
did you have you have the keto flu how
long you been doing it so she has a keto
flu in those days oh yeah you're in the
thick of it brother you almost done the
end I can't see that far you are an Andy
to shame the frame crawled through that
[ __ ] you're like halfway right said it
would take a man 600 years to get out of
this here first Sam I don't wanna but
Andy will find it in left hand corner
sometimes the ladies one yeah I wish I
could say never one old riverboat used
to live right there what a free weekend
stripper get busy living or get busy
dying
that's what to say yeah smoking freedom
me a good stripper huh
yeah with them freckles yeah
I like Freck give me a couple of dollars
Morgan you make it with dollars yes
smoke crack don't you boy don't just
Samms jump sounds dogs to kid King
trippin the gates and seize the day
oh that's Newsies King it man I think
here's one thing if you do you sexually
involve the strippers numbs if they're
cool chicks not they're psychos and they
built like a little Clydesdale sometime
you find these ladies off the interstate
and they've built like a damn little
Clydesdale you know like somebody in
their house and their genealogy is part
Shetland you know someone looked like
that a piece of work of tattoos all over
their ass I celebrate it man some of the
most famous people you know start off as
strippers it's true cardi B yeah blac
chyna Sylvester Stallone dude just a
name a few let's say this I'm gonna go
this blac chyna more black than China I
would say more China than black really
yeah okay prove it tell me why look at
her face
really it's like first of all she looks
white let's do it now faces like this
look at my eyes black or Chinese I don't
know look that's a Nicki Minaj you know
what they look very similar no they do
hold up not that body black that face
China you think so
yeah I'm looking I'm alike in well that
face on on that face hmm you but I could
try and easier to say yeah I don't that
is the face yeah but I think yeah but I
tell more black in China I think but
this is never good King at her sing it
to think about more what do you think
Derrick uh I'm seeing black lips yeah no
come on bro
lip asipi right there boy mrs. lippy
dude she got that real heat pieces right
the next match your sooner sex tape huh
there's no watch all of that that's
right you can't I can I choose not to
drive it to make solid choices in my
life it too you know I don't want you to
not touch me I'll describe it an 11
minute video to my phone okay all right
so that I watch it no I'll just give you
the bullet points I can imagine what
happens at sex Pro it's people [ __ ]
each other looking at the camera a black
eye licks his lips and then the you know
it's over and the skinniest black guy
you've ever seen it really Oh
so it's good yeah I'm saying I'll watch
take that [ __ ]
camera Stan well at least you out racist
to me dude because I was feeling pretty
racism so I'm really I just assume
you're racist with your haircut know
what else we got
we got relationship advice not save
relationship advice
hey allowed to give any advice on
anything after my celebration of
strippers do you only want to hear from
me [ __ ] did you at least had on that
I've never raced it yeah like a gay
cyclist you were like [ __ ] prance
Armstrong first like a [ __ ] hey I
think eighth reindeer all right you like
the eight reindeer skittles up first
this guy no name from this guy okay oh
that's uh that's a Machine Gun Kelly is
Machine Gun Kelly he's a famous rapper
it looks like handgun
Jackson is it looks like dude it looked
like yes fire bullet am g k bro but
let's roll with them I like relationship
advice I need from you guys don't know
this happened to anyone you know or
yourselves but well let's say speak up
for us to blow like ago at the start and
then he scholars me for no reason
London are like those old films she's
laughter I've done the business with him
but warm gung-ho we can throw out to do
and it still happened so maybe can read
me help me I'd appreciate goodbye is
this Brad Sean Pitt Connery dude this
guy I think just embody thank you
confess he murdered somebody you get
over it if you've only listen to this
show that you have to go to youtube and
watch this now because this is just an
unprecedent video this is this is
everything man this is a young man who
could be trapped
who has a very Brad Pitt Fight Club type
of vibe going on a little bit of M&A
8 mile mmm I am staying vibe going on
yeah a little bit of I am saying he's
either in Britain or Scotland maybe or
he's just from Ohio and we can't hear
him really uh-huh
now let's play this man I was running
back to working on this thing Uncle Sam
their big relationship advice I need
from you guys they don't know this up
and tell me what do you know or yourself
but I could throw like a girl at the
start and then for no reason
I run deny like lose old favorites
folder
she's laughter I've done the sessions
with him but one gonna wait and throw
out to do on you still happened so maybe
can remit help me do this and I'd
appreciate goodbye
how old is he hurt you heard somebody
coming in the distance and he said
goodbye real fan I not exactly I mean
somebody's showing up no yeah someone
was kill me to arrest him I think um no
but the thing you how old is he be I
think what's going on here you just
might be young so he's trying to bust
nuts you just haven't met the right one
meet the right one you bust nut still
want a hangout yeah that's what's going
on here
just hanging out chicken heads dude yeah
you're just yeah I mean your bite you
probably just haven't found anybody that
you liked and it used to be if you
didn't find anybody that you like they
wouldn't [ __ ] you and now they'll [ __ ]
you anyway yeah cuz they hate you the
[ __ ] yeah people [ __ ] you just to get
you to leave him alone sometimes yeah
just to leave so I don't know what this
guy's talking about honestly what do you
think Derek what's going on here I think
you have a closer he's asking a he's not
every time he has sex with a girl he
loses interest he has this new girl that
he likes so he's wondering should he
proceed with the sex but he's worried do
lose interest or should he just go on a
real date called ejaculating dude every
time you have sex with a girl
you lose interest and these are thinking
about a different girl that you like
it's called a habit that's called
ejaculation it's gonna be in a man it's
not gonna be in a man I don't think kind
of it's called ejaculating dude dude
you're busting nuts dude I just don't
think he's met the right one
yeah I gotta know how old he is but I
don't think he's met the right one it
happens all the time
I don't want it how old he is I'm just
gonna assume he's an adult okay you're
pretty with some [ __ ] into you in order
to [ __ ] a girl so once you had Doug like
wow she's some really racist [ __ ] I'm
out yeah well I'm like I guess I'll go
to this rally I'm sure I guess as soon
as I bust she's like
like can't make it I'm sorry you can't
make it just some really racist [ __ ] man
that's like an I'm off the racist hook
so Thank You Brenda
all right let's keep it cruising what do
you guys say what do we say to this guy
what do you say perspective let's get a
female perspective from abroad you say
it from abroad Wow
back to the racist guard I agree with
Brendan I just don't think he met the
one plus he's young he needs a whole
round of it
yeah bus nuts did you find one women
saying he needs to Ho around is the deal
I agree these days man I know it's just
hard to hear sometimes get a fish till
you catch the right one you know ya keep
throwing them back in the ocean fine you
want to I'm gonna I'm gonna snap on this
yeah caps a grouper bro they're catching
minnows busting nuts catching minnows
catch that big old grouper to suck y'all
yeah yeah I don't know I'm talking about
I'm sorry if I hurt a man's fishing trip
wait he's off a fishing trip next let's
go next let's keep it moving up next we
got Josh brought bro chill from North
Dakota gang
Josh bro chill CEO Brendan what up gang
gang buzz buzz JB see Josh bro chill
coming at you flub Muscoda just sitting
in the control room Dan up the podcast
going in the background what's he
control for a little bit of our
relationship advice so I got this girl
that lives out in Colorado we used to
date each other actually pretty often we
make trips to see each other that's
beautiful
and we still I feels like we still kind
of like each other but we won't do the
long-distance thing what do you think
should I uh should I give it up move on
or should I just keep doing what I'm
doing not making those flights out there
to get that day well hopefully she
doesn't see this she's not gonna like
that but she knows apparently she knows
what's going on yeah but he's the one
making the trips so she's getting you
know he's definitely doing a you know
he's he there's some chivalry in that
and the fact that he's spending the
money too
there for sure but he also works for
NASA control center do you see a setup
Jesus Christ you have 19 computers we
have so definitely well soon you'll be
able to exterminate the earth between
you and her yeah soon you'll be able to
upload er you're living by the looks of
it um I need to know what this is with
long distance what does she do for work
and obviously you do something important
for work otherwise you don't need 19 TV
screens yeah just chill man yeah for
sure chill bro so I think depend how
much money you make talking and moving
up to North Dakota now that's a tough
sell because Denver's poppin
trust me born and raised they call it
men virtu dude a lot of man up there a
lot of women too though didn't a lot of
landslides it's just too many men have a
jackal-headed over a season and it just
kind of pulls the land I was just all
that moisture hits and pulls the land
down we call Cinnabun season Oh extra
glisten on it that's what I do to always
add a muffin stop one time and some girl
tried to order a Cinnabon ladies like
this just muffins here
did you shout glaze your muffin uh she
goes put extra glistening on it that's
what she said i was like okay she wants
that sticky middle okay no no no I'm
saying you know that's a real thing you
just eat the middles
do you know that cuz they're that
they're his favorite part is the middle
you can order just the middles from
Cinnabon oh [ __ ]
and you wonder why there's sex crimes
going on when Cinnabons offering just
the middle meanwhile you wonder watch
the young women are getting molested
across you know America and a lot of
like you know high high-end
neighborhoods that are politically
motivated circles do you've ever had the
according to Sam Tripoli with this dude
first of all bro chill you have got to
open us some type of a business up there
where you live because that name alone
in Denver bro chill dude you would kill
and open a CBD [ __ ] company in bro
chill CBD or even it's a snow cone you
know open the warm snow cone bro bro
chills warm snow cones
dime why nice bro why nice and
bro chill Hawaiian ice shaved Hawaiian
ice
bro chills [ __ ] ball bags dude just
sell [ __ ] images of your ball bags
Polaroids autograph $4 a pop dude I like
this open a kiosk in the [ __ ] Denver
mall chill bro chill bow with the lady I
think here's the thing you'll do what
you're gonna do for me it seems like
I'll do what I'm gonna do until
something else comes along that piques
my interest more or that you know
there's a reason why you're doing it you
know and some of it might be reasons you
don't even know you might care more
about the girl than you know it might be
like it gives you and it gives you
something to do it gives you an excuse
you like going flying over there let me
drop some knowledge don't but it also
might work because you don't live
together you're not actually in a
relationship you like the idea of flying
there busting nuts for two or three days
then flying back North Dakota yeah but
you guys haven't spent a lot of time
around each other it's not real - you
spend a lot of time around each other
it's very true man
nothing's nicer than being able to get
away from someone that you love often
and and you have that right now so it
could be a blessing yeah so you might be
living the dream brother yeah look yeah
bro chill bro chill chill bro children
with hot dogs we're gonna give me some
flan my heart you guys ready yeah I love
start with mom Angie here this is mama
Angie well I think I met her before can
you tell us a little bit about her day
mama Angie is she loves working out
going to flea markets and she can squat
630 pounds how much is that Brenda she
can ask what will she say 630 pounds she
says 6:30 maybe if she's on those khabib
pills man no sorry I'm she looks like
she's on them [ __ ] cookie pills she's
swole bro she's also pushing her body
very hard up in one direction yeah very
directional she's bigger guns than both
of us though I love her hands she has
the hands you see on like a lot of those
prayer videos you know at church good
you soo min just on the hands look if
you ever see like on those videos of
like donation and prayer and stuff at
church like happy heart or whatever or
you know the happy hearth congregation
on the sign they have it looks like you
guys black tattoo of praying hands
yeah yeah every stripper going back to
you house yeah every outdoor stripper
from Denver she looks like a bricklayer
look at those hands I'll lay that brick
baby damn oh you could build a dang
vestibule around me if she wanted I
think she's beautiful man let's zoom out
on her a little bit
I listen oh if I was in a foxhole I'd
want her big ass around that's no way to
[ __ ] get to her heart bro what do you
mean like if I was in a foxhole I'd have
your big ass around
first of all foxes hide e what the [ __ ]
to even know about foxes dude not a lot
but in the foxhole what I'm saying bro
if shits going down I'm gonna be I feel
protected around her she looks like she
might be in the on the SWAT team she
squats 630 pounds she clearly knows
we're getting illegal steroids there's a
lot going on here oh yeah she has a
biohazard tattoo so she likes to jam is
that what that is yeah it's biohazard
zoom in on that that could be anything
could be a boat propeller it also looks
like it may be some off of the back of
AR but could be a BMW soon - yeah it
could be some motion that she got when
she was at Coachella yeah it could be
also a Jimmy Buffett one of those right
that might not be biohazard like I'm
sticking tats I don't see this beautiful
body
very nice definition look at the claves
you could eat soup out of those [ __ ]
son yeah I'm full rack of ribs up top
there
oh yeah and she has that full she got
that neck oh she's got that neck doing
that crater bro oh dude sniff all the
coca you know like neck it like neck it
Ralph boy let's get naked
you know nectarine is just take our
scars off and get straight [ __ ] neck
itch she looks like a bad [ __ ] she
looks like she just gets in her [ __ ]
old-school Oldsmobile I just hit [ __ ]
Godsmack she drives a fine young chick
around town dude you [ __ ] and you go
get them girl you go get those young
naive women out there what's up you know
what I'm saying that out - somebody's on
me to market right there brush she's
running her own game on the young lady
she said come get me me - yeah get you
some of this meat - Rackham
I'd let her spot me oh yeah the only
female I've ever seen that let spot me
I'd let her spot me like a damn
Dalmatian dude I love her
King Becks we got cousin Felicity this
is cousin felicity damn well goddamn
girl looks like a nice spring day with
some DSL Z so no name for other than his
cousin felicity she's a South African
teacher and the guy who submitted said
that he's had to beat up some guys that
broke her heart but she's done the same
to girls who have done the same to him
because they keep it gang gang he also
referred to his own cousin as an
absolute dying piece there may be some
going on there look man you know what I
say if you really you know cousins
you're good
well you shouldn't have to go far to
[ __ ] that was the old motto dude you
know if you need gas money bro then who
you know do you really need to know that
person you know if you need sugar you
want to across the street yeah your back
rubbed you wanna go across the street
yeah when you get out on the highway man
and we start leaving the family started
you know step on a crack break your
mother's back once you get out near the
sidewalk I said keep it local man [ __ ]
local look at a lot of these different a
lot of sects of humanity they they keep
it in the in the tribe in the tribe
look at the chimps they bang their kind
yeah chimps follow the right Tongans
Hebrews they keep a lot of they keep
their a lot of their dating is within
their tribe Hawaiians Hawaii they're
forced to [ __ ] on the island yeah think
about that dude they're great look how
happy a Hawaiian is you've seen a
satellite know you've seen Moana do
where my sister yeah where my sister
lives people are related bro you throw a
frisbee and no into a field of no one
and someone will catch it that's [ __ ]
possibly related to you yeah
it's that kind of cement birds start
looking like they shouldn't look like
that you know what I'm saying even birds
know if you don't flee don't fly far to
[ __ ] not looking flamingos yeah they're
all the same but mangoes do it yeah
think about that think about that did
you think a flamingo we only have one
blender system
flamingos man I was just a powerful
substitute is she a substitute teacher
she's like a regular English teacher I
Regulus I would learn nothing but boners
if I was in that class yeah well I think
she seems like a nice lady I've learned
more than boners but I probably pay
attention and get a damn education dude
that's right it's why you had to go
fight for money for a [ __ ] decade
that's a legit what I'm sorry man no
it's all the jib ah man I'm being mean
today I think I have a cold that's why
now it's your keto diet oh it probably
is dude dude I swear to god bro
I'll lick a [ __ ] did I'll do a line
of Splenda off a [ __ ] deceased baby's
back right now dog damn that's extreme
well maybe get off the diet it's a dark
art no dude I'm trying to look nice no
you look nice you look normal
oh you look exactly the same whether
they do it or not dude bro I can't even
hear right now okay I would have to die
my abs coming but I can't see your hair
first of all is she's a substitute
teacher if she's dating people you
having a fight for why she have on a
wedding ring maybe that could be yeah
something's going on here yeah maybe
that's your wife dude and I'm not mad at
all King this girl oh I say king is she
beautiful she seems outgoing she's
outdoors clearly nice yeah she's
drinking by a pond she obviously seems
like a fun person she has an accent a
nice set of eyebrows she's teaching
people in South Africa dude it's amazing
drinks a lager beautiful cut of
beautiful country yeah a lager hopping
you know she's used to having a couple
lagers in her throat you know what I'm
saying oh I like this what else you got
Brent is that Paul Bunyan baby you know
I'm not Foster's down you're okay Wow
his hats getting tight Brendan tight
hats do Brendan takes a hat off of like
a baby like a little doll that's in the
room his son's room like Brendan that's
us would you have a purse and do the
little bears how do that you steal your
mom's wigs so we're good yeah only our
show wigs you animal that makes sense
last up this is uncle Bruce uncle Bruce
let's see this pervert
oh my god uncle brews trying to [ __ ]
alright I think uncle Bruce is about to
shoot a porno that's what it looks like
[Laughter]
no bro bro he has to first of all he's
Filipino my hat he makes amazing Chinese
food and he's looking for a nice white
lady to settle down with one day yeah
well he only has one leg that other
thing that's a dick you know he's
one-legged brother that's a dick down
that other pant leg look how it's a
little leaner yeah that [ __ ] one too
meat stick
Oh [ __ ] Wow brother some [ __ ] Manny
Pacquiao
you got that enchilada hitter in his
pants bro he's grilling meat on his
[ __ ] talked about a red talked about
that wet burrito I like this dude what's
his name again
Bruce Wow oh my see sting can you zoom
in on our Polynesian friend please ome
should my ass well he's hiding his face
on to that hat oh wow he's that very coy
Filipino man who do you think he's
Filipino cat that's a Filipino Wow so
whatever why did tell us more cuz if you
know more about Filipino men what's
going on here
let's go live to the source well we know
he has giant calves true
he's clearly I feel like he god I love
Filipino men I'm just you but that's not
your thing is your boyfriend Billy yeah
I like him a little chubbier though like
oh yeah Joey a little more pushing for
the cushion you know oh yeah you like
you're a chubby chaser well I don't like
guys who are like fat guys I like guys
who can cuddle well yes I like guys who
can cuddle well if you're ripped you're
not fun
I don't know let's finally cut loose oh
it looks like you wouldn't but it looks
like a snuggle the [ __ ] out of you can
looks like you're coming with a panther
yeah it's like cuddling with a toaster
so coming with a [ __ ] crocodile yeah
uncle Miguel would be like cuddling
maybe or even throws it down is just an
epic color first of all the guy has
getting dick piece in your back the guy
has 2,000 trophies for being awesome as
[ __ ] one of those trophies for can you
zoom in on those day it looks like some
sort of dodgeball trophy or it looks
like he's running do the ladies their
jobs in all the balls if this dudes in
town bro can you zoom in on waiting
anymore
is that it oh you're running they say he
runs a brothel
I like this I agree and let's make it an
outdoor brothel and let's give our girl
a job you know what I'm saying
own your own [ __ ] business man not to
Miguel Miguel bro hasta luego
yeah shrimp on the barbie what a good
episode man [ __ ] yeah that's cool that
was fun thank you guys so much for all
your submissions and and all the support
if you're listening to the episode try
to check it out on visual because they
got visual stuff yeah you guys make that
so it happen so your submission stuffs
how the shows keep going so keep sending
your submissions
whether it's Mary [ __ ] kill where the we
came up the term or flop my on or
relationship advice yeah make sure you
send those in that's how this episode's
get made where you gonna be Theo you
back on the road bro yeah I'm gonna be
back on the road I got a bunch of new
day just launched a tour right yeah just
dark art store is still going on so if
you already seen it this year then it's
the same as just going back to different
places are going to places I haven't
been so although all the places are
theof on Comm slashed or tou are and
that's it I'll be in New York this week
though just for at Caroline's but it's
sold out oh brother I'm in Tampa next
Friday and Saturday that's May 10th and
11th and then just announced I posted
the trailer on my Instagram and Facebook
my special May 17
Showtime Friday 10:00 p.m. first comedy
special beh beh beh beh
it looks good man the intro is it the
whole thing you shove me no I just did
the I'm gonna pop post that next week
there that thing is good I was gonna be
bad and it's good you guys you'd be
surprised right yes sir
continually thank you guys for checking
out King in the string man Gang Gang
buzz-buzz
[Music]